[Music]
oh my gosh
uh cool cool cool cool cool cool
everything is going great hi guys i'm
matt welcome back to my kitchen i'm
joined by my roommate everett hi
everyone so tonight i thought it would
be fun to take on a little challenge i
am going to try and make my chipotle
order faster than it can be delivered
and my delivery person is none other
than my own roommate he said free food
i'm here to pick it up so
that's good tonight i will be making
white rice black beans chicken pico de
gallo and guacamole to make my ideal
burrito bowl because burrito bowls are
the best thing at chipotle will your
guac cost extra no my guac is free five
stars do you think i can do it the
chipotle is only nine minutes from here
i think it might be a little tougher
than the big mac challenge
yeah but uh you might be able to do it i
might be in over my head either way
there's free chipotle at the end
okay
order
hold to submit are you ready let's do it
three
two
oh go go go go go okay first things
first i need to make my rice and to
expedite that
i'm gonna use a rice cooker because it's
a good idea so i want to add about two
cups here
let's say
more than that that looks good to me and
before i even finish this i'm going to
wash my rice
oh this is taking up so much time just
washing my rice cool cool cool i've got
my rice here i'm going to go ahead and
add just a couple bay leaves for some
flavoring boom very ceremoniously put
the top on this my rice is all set i'm
just going to let this cook and move on
to my beans beans beans beans beans what
are the beans what are the beans what
are the beans what it means okay so for
my beans i just need to prep my
onion i feel like i'm just standing at
the edge of an abyss okay so give this
just a nice chop that is my onion now to
just get through my garlic i'm just
gonna chop all these guys up
all right time to start making these
beans
just for the record i do have to say if
you guys can
find yourself a tasty producer roommate
the amount of times this man has cooked
for me it's incredible
for my beans i am going to need oil
honestly that feels warm enough so i'm
going to throw my onions
give that all a stir i just want these
to soften and get a bit translucent now
it's time to add that much garlic let
this go for about a minute
oh my gosh
i'm sorry
i'm happy with this now it's time to add
the black beans
and some water
perfect great so at this point i just
need to move on to my chicken for this
i'm just using chicken thighs get them
nice and dry i want to get any excess
moisture off of them i am sweating like
nothing else it's time for a little bit
of salt pepper get the other side
perfect
going to set this aside
that's the second red light he's getting
awfully lucky awfully lucky if you ask
me
to make the marinade for the chicken i'm
keeping it nice and simple i'm just
going to use canned chipotles and adobo
a nice chop
perfect and then i'm just going to
transfer all of this to a bowl
i'm actually going to add back my
chicken thighs boom and i'm just going
to give it all a good little toss i am
just going to set this aside let it
marinate for a few minutes before i cook
it now i'm going to get started on my
pico de gallo really quickly just going
to chop up these two tomatoes
oh no
when i say chip you say olay chip chip
i don't hear you
i am pulling up to the chipotle as we
speak we are almost there
perfect tomatoes go into my bowl cut you
in half
ah i love a red onion
and you go and finally one jalapeno
slice that guy in half that's a big
jalapeno
do that and finally i'm just going to go
with
all of this cilantro
smells delightful oh my god i love
chipotle okay let's give matt a call
hello hey bud oh no why why are you
calling
i'm on my way back right now oh my god
okay consider yourself lucky because the
chicken was not ready they had to make
new chicken oh no okay well i'll see you
soon i'm doing great i'm way ahead of
you i'll drive really really slow thank
you just kidding
okay i am running out of time that is
all of my cilantro wow everything is
getting very messy and very chaotic
really quick okay lime cut in half gonna
add a little bit of salt a little bit of
lime give this all
a good stir pico de gallo is done oh i'm
gonna go with a bowl that's way too big
for my guac i have my avocado i have my
onion i have my jalapeno i'm going to
add approximately that cilantro ah let's
get a lime in there come on oh i can't
squeeze my lime i feel like i sound like
a rick and morty character have i been
using this voice the whole time
red light
green light
oh
different headlights different
headlights okay uh salt uh pepper just
because
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh no
come on
come on
hey how's it going
chipotle
chicken bowl cilantro rice
it's pretty good
[Music]
okay as far as guacamole i'm happy with
that okay everything is almost done i am
so freaking close let's cook up this
chicken everett is still not back so i
think i'm still in this my pan is
heating over medium-high heat just going
to grease this nicely oh this is
such a bad idea
still no one back yet
oh i'm right down the street
i don't think he's gonna make it
let's go let's go let's go
my chicken is in the pan i'm so close i
just need to finish this i need to do
some final touches on my rice when it's
done beans are looking good
oh no oh no is that a door
no
i'm so close
sorry
i got the chipotle all right okay so
i've already lost but i still have time
to finish this really quickly so let's
see how much slower i am than chipotle
rice is done i'm gonna get to you in a
minute i should have started this before
i started the
wok and the pico that's fine we all live
and make mistakes that looks good just
give that a flip
flip
these look great i'm going to let them
go for a few more minutes on the burner
behind me and wrap up my rice i'm just
going to fluff
all of my rice up some lime juice
a little bit of cilantro toss
all of this
and voila there is my cilantro lime rice
pop the lid on this
set it aside my beans are looking good
i'm just gonna pull out that little bay
leaf there i have
a little bit of chipotle chili pepper
some cumin
a little bit of pepper
some salt
finally
a little bit of oregano give that all a
nice stir
oh that smells so good
okay beans are done
here we are after an endless slog
everything has been made let's bring it
all together i'm gonna start with my
rice
it smells the part and then i'm going to
add my beans
oh yeah and then of course
my chicken probably should have chopped
up smaller but you know what it's
gourmet a little bit of our chunky pico
i'm just gonna add that off to the side
here no extra cost for guac so i'm gonna
put a big old dollop of you on top look
at that and finally just for some
creaminess
not as creamy as i thought
and there we have it that is my homemade
chipotle burrito bowl here it is
nice and lukewarm
ready to go how much longer did i take
22 minutes and 56 seconds longer
okay so you can't make chipotle
in the amount of time it takes to have
it delivered at least i can but you know
what this was made with love and at the
end of the day that's all that matters
all right everett has a look this
honestly looks incredible firstly
chipotle and you really hooked it up
with a guac and i'm loving how much
crema you put on there it looks amazing
and i really just want to eat it you
know it may have taken me 20 minutes
longer but guess what it's now finally
time to eat let's do it
listen that's the thing about chipotle
you can always count on it yeah it's
always going to be great it's always
going to be delicious and they really
hook this bowl up that's good i love
chipotle i'm a sucker fish bully you
want to try this one let's do it
oh god
matt actually not bad that's delicious
that guac is amazing thank you the
jalapenos are like big enough so you
really get that bite every single time
and this grandma is so
good that's a pro tip you guys you gotta
do it with the crema it's amazing
grandma makes it
delicious i get that it took me 20
minutes longer to make it but this is a
pretty good knockoff you know for a
homemade one i think it's completely
worth it i may have lost i may have been
really slow 20 minutes slower but i am
happy
she came with the receipts
okay since i was 22 minutes
thank you
and there you have it i tried to race my
chipotle order didn't make it but still
good in the end everett thank you so
much for being my delivery driver you're
so welcome anytime at if you have any
suggestions for fast food takeout
delivery meals you want us to try let us
know in the comments below or you can
message me on instagram and until next
time take care guys bye
oh yes
[Music]
do
[Music]
you